[Music]
Doug Williams the VP of player personnel
in Washington talking about the
quarterback situation did not rule out
Alex Smith although most believe he will
not be playing this year after that
badly broken leg during the 2018 season
said Williams it's our job in the
personnel department to find somebody
who can play thank God we have Colt
McCoy coming back from an injury we've
just got to find somebody to mix in
there and we know we've got to have that
guy but we got to build around whoever
it is I think that's the most important
thing boy that that that that does not
sound very promising I think that they
know that Alex Smith is is not going to
be back anytime soon if ever they gave
him a ton of guaranteed money last year
and at some point people are gonna
realize Bruce Allen why did you feel
compelled to give Alex Smith a long-term
contract on his way in the door I did
wonder [ __ ] right right they wanted to
avoid the franchise tag dance again like
they had with Kirk Cousins and I think
that's why they did it but they they
shouldn't have done it now it's rare
that you have that kind of serious
injury for a quarterback but it happened
Chris they don't have a whole lot of
options because they're not gonna have
the money to go out and spend on a
big-name quarterback no I mean you're
right I mean they they overpaid for Alex
Smith I don't think there's any denying
that I understand what they were doing
they're trying to set up the the
framework or their football team in
something which they did not have the
years before that to say this guy is the
leader of our team he's the general he's
the guy we got to follow it all went
downhill from there nick foles
I mean does that happen that the Eagles
have the guts to trade him within the
division I don't know you know Colt
McCoy he is not the worst option in the
world I do like that maybe they do bring
in a Ryan Tannehill right to compete
with Colt McCoy and they played the best
guy through a quarterback battle
something like that but if they would do
that tag and trade it's 25 million that
the Washington franchise would have to
absorb how do you do that when you've
got so much money invested in Alex
Smith's contract from last year and that
guarantee you know usually we look at
the injury guarantee and say oh that's
meaningless for quarterbacks they never
have serious injuries well sometimes
they do and that money is going to be on
the books and it's gonna make it harder
for Washington to get another guy they
may just have to draft somebody and
develop somebody I hope there
for for dropping to Lodi
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports